every once in a while leftist will slip
up and tell us what they really think
about America in a recent interviewed
new york's new socialist it girl grapes
that older democrats in congress aren't
doing more to support a new crop of
progressive candidates a lot of these
folks were in their political heyday in
third way 90's politics i think that
politically this like upper middle class
is probably more moderate but that
upper-middle class doesn't exist anymore
in america you know their heyday was in
the 90s when like you know kids had like
fur bees and like parents so you had
like soccer moms like two vans and stuff
like Furbies that's that america anymore
she said like seven times in that little
five times in two sentences i believe
something like i was trying to almost
running out of fingers as if she knows
all of america from her loft and queens
and by the way what does she think the
moms outside of big cities can what cart
their kids around on those dippy
electric scooters or something oh my
goodness all kidding aside what she
seems to be saying and it's kind of hard
to dissect it is that the new generation
of women today are less moderate and I
suppose closer to her socialist views
and I'm not sure what minivans have to
do with it and by the way I happen to
love my minivan it rocks but I've never
met a single mother who owned two of
them but okay of Cortez's political
magic apparently wasn't working last
night because as most of her preferred
candidates lost and most of them by
double digits the real story was that in
the heartland moderate Democrats are
looking strong we'll get to more of that
story later on in the show nevertheless
she's kind of right in a general sense
because in some parts of the country it
does seem like the America that we know
and love doesn't exist anymore massive
demographic changes have been foisted
upon the American people
and their changes that none of us have
were voted for and most of us don't like
from Virginia to California we see stark
examples of how radically in some ways
the country has changed now much of this
is related to both illegal and in some
cases legal immigration that of course
progressives love remember the old
Democrats maybe some of them that
Acacio Cortez referring to they used to
think that borders mattered but the new
activists believed enforcing immigration
laws is essentially an ongoing human
rights violation of course they want to
abolish ice and so forth well today we
were reminded again of why our law has
to be enforced border strengthened and
the wall built loopholes closed and
sanctuary city policies ended once and
for all
check out what happened courtesy of
Philadelphia's refusal to cooperate with
ice detainers in May of 2009 Juan Ramon
Vasquez a citizen of Honduras was
deported from the United States just
five years later in March 2014 ice
officers found out that Vasquez was back
in the US and was in custody with the
Philadelphia Department of prisons
Philadelphia however refused to comply
with an ice detainer request so Vasquez
was instead released from custody after
his release Vasquez was re-arrested and
ultimately convicted for child rape this
is an unspeakable act of evil that
should have never occurred and never
occurred on American soil remember when
the current mayor of Philly did this
after a judge ruled in favor of his city
sanctuary status oh my god what an
embarrassment at this point I would hope
the voters in Philadelphia
would see the light in send Mayor James
Kenney packing he's a disgrace if only
such heartbreaking stories though were
isolated events they're not last weekend
in Colorado Springs a police officer 7
Giselle was critically injured he was
shot by an Iraqi refugee allowed into
the u.s. under President Obama
Carano Mon Alka Massey had been ordered
deported after a felony trespassing
probation violation only to be released
by a judge who cited changes in the law
it was beyond tragic and for all of you
who are buying into the media narrative
about the horrors perpetrated on
children who are kept temporarily in HHS
custody who've crossed the border the
kids have crossed the border illegally
consider an actual horror an illegal who
crossed the border with a child he
claimed was his own well that illegal
adult turned out to be the child's
rapist Ramon Pedro showed up at a border
crossing in Texas last April he said he
was traveling with his daughter and he
demanded entry into the u.s. well like
thousands of other family units they
were processed and then released into
the United States called catch and
release well late last month at a
routine health screening doctors
discovered the girl had been sexually
assaulted salted allegedly by him and it
gets worse it turns out the young girl's
mother knew that this coyote was a
sexual predator but sent her daughter
with him anyway because the mother was
promised ultimately later on a job who
are these people
we're really smart mother of the Year
award they're not well who is going to
make the argument that this poor abused
and brutalized girl wouldn't have been
safer in u.s. detention than with a
rapist and on my radio show today I
received this call from Travis from
Nevada who told of his own personal loss
at the
again of an illegal alien my brother and
April was killed by an illegal alien
while he and his son and his girlfriend
were out on a a planned bike ride as
some was 9-year is nine years old and oh
my gosh doing 60 miles an hour on a side
street and hit him on his bicycle the
district attorney has said that he you
know confirmed that he isn't illegal and
was there a lot of news coverage I
didn't see any news coverage of this
story and I track all these stories he's
right it's something the president by
the way pointed out just a few months
ago the media doesn't talk about the
American families permanently separated
from their loved ones because Democrat
policies release violent criminals into
our communities and if you're under the
impression that these illegal crossings
are somehow slowing down well new data
released in the last 24 hours tells a
very different story
Border Patrol apprehensions at the
southwest border rose more than 70
percent year-over-year agents
apprehended 31 thousand three hundred
and three people in July up from
eighteen thousand 187 a year ago and
while it's good that they're being
apprehended we should you know be a
little bit alarm don't you think that
they feel like they're entitled to keep
coming across the border and by the way
there were three thousand nine hundred
thirty eight unaccompanied children
apprehended last month that's up from
two thousand four hundred and seventy
five a year ago with another nine
thousand two hundred and fifty eight
families apprehended that was up from
3389 last July now I know those are
numbers but we have to these are our
people
a lot of people it's a lot that this
country has to process and ultimately
most of them are released and what about
those who come here on valid visas well
guess what more than six hundred
thousand of those who came on visas
overstayed them in 2017 this is another
completely absurd scenario everyone is
gaming the system now this is a sure way
over time to remake and reshape America
this is exactly what socialists like
Ocasio Cortez want eventually diluting
and overwhelming your vote with the
votes of others who aren't let's face it
too big on Adam Smith and the Federalist
Papers and as for those minivan driving
women from the 1990s well newsflash
Alexandria most of them are still alive
and they vote and I bet most of them
don't like the lawlessness at the border
and the crime it brings into our country
I have to believe that most American
women are smarter than to fall into the
socialism open borders trap it's clear
that we need a reset on the entire issue
of immigration illegal and legal it's
time that the president gives a formal
address to the nation preferably one
from the Oval Office he should lay out
his agenda and the cost to the nation of
not pursuing it as he said before
merit-based legal immigration is
fantastic but what we have now is a
complete farce and we're all paying for
it some as you saw with those examples
more than others the president can be so
persuasive so give us the whole truth
mr. president the good the bad and yes
the uncomfortable this is a national
emergency and he must demand that
Congress act now there is something
slipping away in this country and it's
not about race or ethnicity it's what
was once a common understanding by both
parties that American citizenship is a
privilege and one that at a minimum
requires respect for the rule of law and
loyalty to our Constitution and that's
the angle